hi um this is buzzfeed and we're playing
a game of who's who's what you just tom
was supposed to do it why'd you point at
me then because
remember when you pointed to me for most
likely to not know my lines that was me
yeah i'm tom hopper and here
here right go again i'm david castaneda
i'm emmy ray relatman i'm justin h and
i'm tom hopper and we are the cast of
umbrella academy with buzzfeed to do a
game of who's who
brother umbrella academy
[Music]
tom david castaneda emmy
just oh yeah we all are burning it
there's no agreeance here yeah that's
the thing there's no wow yeah
next question
justin
justin you don't want to be like allison
do you no no no no
dude
yeah no i mean
i can understand why season one and two
yeah yeah yeah different people yeah
yeah because once that's when i was
going up one and two you really had to
put it on because i'm the mean guy
season three that's just that's it
just means you're a good actor honey
thank you
a certain oh you think oh actually yes
david
can't be trusted or found most of the
time because he's napping it's actually
a gift it's honestly a gift it's a gift
floors sofas other people's beds no
one's safe no what's that no it's a
feeling
from your
you're biased there's some
bias there yeah it's all of them for me
i have individual moments with all of
you that brighten my day yeah that's a
tricky one
i'm going to say pogo actually you said
me though you don't even know you just
think you should just give it to me
justin
what no actually i'm just kidding
tom is the one that makes me laugh
justin said i don't make people laugh no
i'm not a comedian um it's me come on
guys
i think i think it's robert robert would
be the one yeah
i mean the best one for me was in the
lift last in season two was the oh oh in
the boomerang
yeah yeah
that sounds amazing
after i started so that's always wearing
not a lot of clothes yeah yeah no it was
the like heavens
heavens to betsy he has a line where he
comes in and says heavens to betsy which
killed me
tom aiden
i back myself yeah tom yeah yeah
actually you though i think maybe tom
because he's tall his health is top tier
he can reach the trees for fruit
substance there's an apocalypse so there
are no trees it depends on what
survival techniques you need or know to
survive that because if it's a zombie
apocalypse that's one thing then just if
it's like a nuclear war apocalypse
everyone's wiped out and likely yeah i
mean
um
what do you mean i'm i'm going to
survive the nucleus you said it i just
agreed i love that i love my odds i just
feel like no one would survive but let's
play that but i would unless there's
trees and then i will unless there's
[Music]
for sure he was a fan of the comic books
[Music]
he was a steel trap that one very
involved yeah
[Music]
tom oh
just jump right on it
black parade for sure he actually has a
great singing voice he's really good oh
yeah thank you you'll get to see it and
that's no no no no no no
no in the karaoke bar that i will be
debuting at this friday yeah
that's today
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
well you can say by the reaction you can
already tell me me me me
and me yes she's watched every single
true crime show every podcast i'm a
murderino for sure yeah you know i feel
like you couldn't measure and like you
would get away with it i know something
how's it going but also yeah how to you
know all the little nooks and crannies
of the way i have an eye for you
yeah yeah if someone of us if one of us
did something really bad we call emmy
yeah that's true thank you guys you're
like emmy help me hide this cat
not a cat
it's not that hard to avoid though is it
a cat is it you could just barely just
put it in the yeah emmy what would you
do is it alive
no it's dead you burn it this really
took a turn oh you'd burn it i've seen
those sphinx cats i love the naked cats
i'm obsessed with the title of your
memoir
we're just skinned with the skin
david why me wait i just i just asked
you i always have a wife you always have
coffee
yeah and apples
yes
always asking for food yeah all the time
yeah you sleep and eat that's all you
want you and i eat
i have i've always got like a meal
i'm always snacking i know you're always
fine he's fine
he's farm to table at your craft room
you're always eating chips and soup
no i'm eating gummy worms no
gummy worms
and you have boom chicka pop-pops
i'm a big popcorn girl all those gummy
sweets that were going around those like
were they smart sweets oh yeah that's
smart they're like
sugar-free
smart sweets smart sweets
tom me i'm torn
because there's no it depends what the
problem is either david or emmy wait why
not me i've never talked about
but not me yeah very unhealthy
[Music]
help
[Music]
jordan
well first of all she's a robot yeah so
so she would always she's the most
likely suspect jordan's a perfectionist
in the best way yeah i think she
she wants to get exactly right yeah so i
feel like she'd love a do-over button
honestly i would too though
castaneda yeah especially the robert
redford one rubber redbird and also you
love the uh zac galapanos that this one
is like
but you love that you love the hell of
darkness hello friend yeah oh hello
my old friend
love you it's a gift it's a gift this is
his own gift it's it's a meme that i
created when david comic-con yeah
comic-con in brazil my name is looking
directly down the barrel
it's on my fridge
not last season but season one when i
was next to you in your trailer it was
so loud your music was wow the truth
comes out yeah i had an email from one
of the producers sending me a kind of a
nice note saying hey would you mind
turning it down people don't feel safe
around you oh without the weight that
wasn't me though that was me people
don't feel safe
because the drivers they knew i was
coming in because the drivers i bumped
the music really really high and so i'd
come in and so the drivers were like we
can't drive with you but why were they
why did they feel threatened because i
guess they couldn't hear the street
lights that's dangerous
street lights
you need to hear street lights street
lights
don't know what's happening here
[Music]
tom hopper
you're number two sir guilty the thing
is we do all the time
put your
it's his character don't worry about it
all right thanks a lot buzzfeed for
having us you know you guys rock next
time we're back we'll bring the whole
cast
and watch umbrella academy on netflix
exclusively where are all the rest of
the cows oh
they blinked
help
[Music]
you